[Musik]
300.000 schüler in quarantäne sagte
lehre verband warnt vor
schulschließungen und fordert besseren
corona schutz
das ende der demokratie in hongkong nach
dem rauswurf von pro demokratischen
abgeordneten verlässt die fraktion
geschlossen das parlament und
schutzmaske stadt pappnase deutschlands
karnevalshochburgen starten an diesem
elfter elfter still in die saison
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem mittwoch norbert lehmann ist auch
dabei für den sportstandort von mir die
korona pandemie wird sich zunehmend auch
in den schulen aus die sollen diesmal ja
unbedingt offen bleiben aber immer mehr
schüler und lehrer müssen in quarantäne
und so sagt der lehrer verband immer
mehr schulen müssen wegen corona
schließen
nach hochrechnungen des verbands sind
aktuell 300 tausend schüler in corona
quarantäne
das entspricht einem anteil von 27
prozent der insgesamt elf millionen
schüler in deutschland
außerdem seien bis zu 30.000 lehrer
vorsorglich isoliert
die schutzmaßnahmen in den schulen
gingen nicht weit genug
ralf schipp franzky mit mehr die theater
ag am domgymnasium in magdeburg sie
proben für emilia galotti nur mit maske
wie auch im unterricht und doch schlägt
auch hier corona zu nicht nur für
lessing gilt ein trauerspiel
wir hatten ein corona fall der sich am
wochenende zeigt an einem wochenende und
daraufhin haben wir das dem
gesundheitsamt gemeldet und das hat dann
entschieden eine 14-tägige quarantäne
pflicht für eine klasse einen kurs und
acht lehrer anzusetzen
also hat man schon gemerkt dass es dann
doch erschreckender ist wenn das dann
vor der haustür steht so ein crooner
familiärer die damit zu tun hatten
diesen ja dann in quarantäne gegangen
und wir konnten anhalt weiter machen
eigentlich ganz gut die empfehlung des
robert koch instituts sieht für
risikogebiete eigentlich als
vorsorgemaßnahme vor masken pflicht an
den schulen und die klassen halbieren
doch zum ärger des lehrerverbandes
überlassen die länder die entscheidung
den gesundheitsämtern die politik
erweckt er den eindruck dieses
wechselmodell mit verkleinerten klassen
sei genauso schlimm wie eine komplette
schulschließung da wissen wir alle dass
das nicht der fall ist natürlich ist
voll unterricht besser aber hybrid
unterricht ist immer noch dreimal besser
als die komplette schulschließung in
bayern gilt bei einem corona fall muss
die ganze klasse für 14 tage in
quarantäne
andere bundesländer schicken nur die
sitznachbarn nach hause uns ist wichtig
uns allen dass der präsenzunterricht
stattfindet und viele der maßnahmen die
jetzt ergriffen worden sind und die auch
dazu führen dass sich viele einschränken
müssen sind auch deshalb ergriffen
worden
dann mit schulen und kitas offen bleiben
können damit kinder ihr recht dort
verwirklichen können der bundeselternrat
aber spricht von einem flickenteppich
und schlimmer noch es sei versäumt
worden konzepte für den quarantäne
notfall zu erarbeiten
wir müssen aber wenn es zu schließungen
kommt aufgrund von quarantäne oder
infektionsfällen müssen wir dafür sorge
tragen dass unsere schülerinnen und
schülern eine betreuung haben und b
letztendlich auch wirklich unterricht
genießen können noch aber gilt die
direktive die schule geht weiter und das
theater auch nordrhein-westfalen hat
sich jetzt entschieden die
weihnachtsferien wegen der pandemie zwei
tage früher beginnen zu lassen
seit zehn tagen gelten jetzt in
deutschland die zusätzlichen corona
regeln
die große frage ist ob sie wirken und
sich tatsächlich deutlich weniger
menschen infizieren gesundheitsminister
sparen äußerte sich heute erstmals
vorsichtig optimistisch axel konrad mit
aktuellen zahlen und einschätzungen die
zahlen die neue ansteckungen mit dem
corona virus sie steigen weiter 18 1487
fälle melden die gesundheitsämter heute
verglichen mit dem mittwoch vor einer
woche ein anstieg um mehr als 1000 doch
blickt man auf die entwicklung der
vergangenen wochen mit dem sprunghaften
anstieg seit anfang oktober so ist seit
einigen tagen ein abflachen der kurve zu
beobachten was wir sehen ist dass die
dynamik sich deutlich reduziert hat in
den letzten tagen also steigt noch aber
es steigt weniger stark auch das ist
erstmal ermutigend aber das reicht noch
nicht
wir müssen runter mit den zahlen
virologen waren noch sei es zu früh die
zahlen überhaupt zu bewerten und die
kanzlerin blickt eher skeptisch in die
kommenden monate wie das auch bei der
spanischen grippe der fall war muss man
jetzt davon ausgehen dass die zweite
welle welle härter ist und sie fällt vor
allen dingen in eine schlechtere
jahreszeit nämlich in die wintermonate
das heißt sie wird uns noch den ganzen
winter beschäftigen
wie hart die zweite welle ist zeigt sich
auch daran wie viele menschen an kuwait
19 täglich sterben 261 in den
vergangenen 24 stunden so viele waren es
zuletzt im april
die hoffnungen ruhen jetzt auf dem
impfstoff und darauf dass der teil
locker und wirkung zeigt so wie in
berchtesgaden hier gelten bereits seit
drei wochen massiver einschränkungen die
zahl der neuinfektionen hat sich
mittlerweile halbiert
alle zahlen und grafiken zum corona
virus jederzeit auch zu finden in
unserer zdf heute app da sehen sie auch
wie sich die lage in ihrem landkreis
entwickelt ins ausland es ist ein
weiterer großer einschnitt in hongkong
alle pro demokratischen abgeordneten im
parlament haben heute ihren rücktritt
bekanntgegeben
sie protestieren damit gegen den
rauswurf von vier abgeordneten ihrer
fraktion
diese waren ausgeschlossen worden weil
sie sich für die unabhängigkeit der
sonderverwaltungszone einsetzen
die regierung in peking hatte er kurz
zuvor hongkongs behörden dazu ermächtigt
haben wir unsere korrespondentin in
peking stephanie schöneborn ist das
jetzt ein weiterer sargnagel für die
demokratie in hongkong
naja dieser geschlossene rücktritt
fühlte sich schon an wie pure
verzweiflung
es ist so dass der letzte rest von
autonomie und freiheit in hongkong durch
den ausschluss der parlamentarier
auch hongkong genommen wurde faktisch
ist es so im im namen der des
sogenannten sicherheits gesetzes werden
die ganze zeit schon kritiker
festgenommen und nun wissen wir seit
heute dass auch die opposition zu jedem
zeitpunkt aus dem parlament
ausgeschlossen werden kann
obendrauf muss man jetzt sagen wenn wir
den heutigen tag der heutige tag zeigt
vor allen dingen eins und das ist dass
die pekinger regierung mit voller wucht
versucht die demokratiebewegung in
hongkong vollends den den den garaus zu
machen und sie kommen
zu beseitigen dankeschön für diese
einschätzung aus peking stephanie
schöneborn in den usa bereitet sich der
gewählte präsident joe biden trotz des
widerstands von donald trump auf die
regierungsübernahme vor er nannte es
peinlich dass der präsident seine
niederlage nicht einräume
das jump team spricht weiter von
wahlfälschung ohne beweise vorlegen zu
können aus washington pte
der regen prasselt auf ihn herunter als
donald trump mit ehefrau melania am
soldatenfriedhof in arlington eintrifft
die traditionelle kranzniederlegung zu
ehren gefallener soldaten ist für den
staatschef am veteranen tag pflicht auch
bei seinem ersten öffentlichen termin
nach der wahl hüllt sich in schweigen
der designierte präsident joe biden
gedenkt heute in philadelphia der
soldaten eher präsentiert sich wie
gestern gern der presse was er davon
hält dass trump seine niederlage noch
immer nicht eingestanden hat will eine
reporterin wissen das ist offen gesagt
eine peinlichkeit
wie kann ich das jetzt taktvoll
rüberbringen ich glaube es wird seinem
vermächtnis als präsident nicht helfen
im bundesstaat georgia steht unterdessen
eine neuauszählung an und zwar per hand
der republikanische innenminister war
damit dem wunsch des tramp teams
nachgekommen
der präsident legt hier um rund 14.000
stimmen hinten
es wird eine herausforderung werden aber
wir arbeiten mit allen bezirken zusammen
für ein zertifiziertes ergebnis wir
arbeiten alle hart damit sich der faire
und korrekte wille der wähler im
endergebnis widerspiegelt
unwahrscheinlich dass eine neuauszählung
in georgia seinen auszug aus dem weißen
haus verhindern kann
dorthin kehrt trump direkt nach der
zeremonie zurück für die nächsten tage
hat er keine weiteren termine in polen
ist heute tag der unabhängigkeit diesen
anlass haben nationalisten und
zahlreiche rechtsextreme genutzt um ihre
parole
zu skandieren da der warschauer
bürgermeister die kundgebung wegen
corona verboten hatte fuhr zunächst ein
autokorso durch die stadt viele ließen
die fahrzeuge aber einfach stehen und
zogen mit fackeln zu fuß weiter vor
allem in den letzten stunden kam es
immer wieder zu zusammenstößen mit der
polizei
stichwort corona und konjunktur in
deutschland nach dem gutachten der
wirtschaftsweisen bricht die wirtschaft
in diesem jahr weniger stark ein als
erwartet
in seinem jahresgutachten spricht der
sachverständigenrat beim
bruttoinlandsprodukt von einem minus von
5,1 prozent für 2021 sagen die ökonomen
ein wachstum von 3,7 prozent voraus
die pandemie wirft auch ein schlaglicht
auf die probleme in der pflege zum
beispiel die situation auf den
intensivstationen auf denen immer mehr
cupid patienten landen betten und
technik sind noch ausreichend vorhanden
eng wird es bei spezialisierten
pflegerinnen und pflegern caroline wie
man hat nachgerechnet
etwa jedes fünfte intensiv bett kann
nicht belegt werden weil es an personal
fehlt mindestens 3500 bis 4000 intensiv
pflegekräfte fehlen als ein
wünschenswerter personalschlüssel gilt
dass eine pflegekraft sich um höchstens
zwei schwer kranke kümmert gesetzlich
gilt zurzeit die regelungen dass sie bis
zu zweieinhalb intensiv patienten
versorgen muss selbst diese personal
untergrenze musste in der ersten
ko-runde ausgesetzt werden
damit jede pflegekraft noch mehr
intensiv patienten betreuen konnte die
zahl der verfügbaren intensivbetten
stieg im sommer auf mehr als 32.000 seit
august ist die personal untergrenze
wieder in kraft und die zahl der
verfügbaren betten liegt wieder bei rund
28.000 um die personal situation zu
verbessern setzen die krankenhäuser auf
umschichtung und weiterbildung
das sind daten die beim deutschen
pflegetag heute jedem bewusst sein
dürften viel zeit sei verloren worden
sagt der präsident des pflegerats die
politik habe den tatsächlichen
personalbedarf lange kleingerechnet für
die kliniken heißt das sie müssen sehen
wie sie jetzt mit der aktuellen
situation irgendwie klarkommen nicola
albrecht
er selbst ausnahmezustand im klinikum
niederlausitz in brandenburg wegen der
steigenden zahl von corona
intensivpatienten muss umgerüstet werden
die pflegekräfte sind enorm beansprucht
zudem gibt es wie fast in allen kliniken
ein besuchsverbot wir dürfen diese
aufnahmen nur mit einem negativen corona
test machen kathrin helm und leitet das
pflegeteam auf der schlaganfallstation
den stress nicht auf die patienten
übertragen wenn das gelingt so schon
viel gewonnen
die probleme sind nicht neu bereits vor
zwei jahren fehlten 80.000 pflegekräfte
in deutschlands krankenhäusern
doch nun sei die lage verschärft
erklären die veranstalter des deutschen
pflege tags in berlin
in diesem jahr digital inklusive
grußbotschaft der kanzlerin
sie nennt die pflege gelebte
menschlichkeit die bessere
rahmenbedingungen brauche warme worte
die angesichts der dringlichkeit in der
pandemie nicht reichten kritisieren sie
hier
wir fordern jetzt von der politik dafür
zu sorgen dass wir zum beispiel den
krankenhäusern planbare behandlungen
stoppen dass wir kapazitäten schaffen
zur unterstützung des pflegepersonals
auf den intensivstationen und auf den
corona intensivstationen ist der druck
bundesweit besonders hoch es ist extrem
aufwendig im gegensatz zu in
anführungsstrichen normalen
intensivpatienten diese corona patienten
vernünftig zu versorgen
trotz schwieriger lage kräfte bündeln
und optimistisch bleiben das ist die
devise von kathrin hellmund und ihrem
team jetzt zu einem fast schon
filmreifen einbruch in emmerich in
nordrhein westfalen haben diebe 6,5
millionen euro erbeutet
drei männer hatten am ersten november
eine kellertür des zollamts aufgehebelt
und sich mit einem bohrer durch die wand
zugang zum tresorraum verschafft die
polizei informierte erst heute über die
höhe der beute zusammen mit
fahndungsfotos der verdächtigen für
hinweise die zur ergreifung führen gibt
es 100.000 euro belohnung
der elfte hälfte eigentlich für alle
karnevalisten und fasnachter ein
besonderes datum die kampagne beginnt
hier ein foto vom auftakt in köln
allerdings aus dem letzten jahr diesmal
sieht es so aus die straßen verweist
polizei und ordnungsamt kontrollieren ob
die korona regeln eingehalten werden
das herz schlägt zu hause so hat jemand
die lage hier auf kölsch treffend
zusammengefasst diana becker über dem
nicht karneval am rhein in mainz wollten
sich die fastnacht fans den 11.11 heute
nicht so ganz nehmen lassen
doch richtige feierstimmung kam auch
hier nicht auf das ordnungsamt schickte
sie nach hause zu nicht corona zeiten
feiern in den hochburgen hunderttausende
karnevalisten das virus verdirbt ihnen
ihre saisoneröffnung in düsseldorf
herrschte trostlose leere
totenstille auch in köln
musik kommt wenn man im radio spielen
der lautsprecher an machen mit musik bin
etwas traurig aber verzichten das
hoppeditz erwachen in düsseldorf fand
heute im leeren raum per live stream
statt persönlich auftreten durfte er nur
vor der presse strikte vorgaben sollten
die menschen abhalten sich in den
städten zu treffen in köln gilt sogar
ein alkoholverbot bis morgen früh
tagsüber ist es weitgehend ruhig
geblieben ordnungsamt und polizei sind
im dauereinsatz
wir werden weiter hier präsent sein und
im bedarfsfall eingreifen
bislang war das allerdings noch nicht
nötig hemmungsloses feiern karneval oder
fastnacht wie gewohnt all das muss wegen
corona ausfallen
die kölner ist das schwer das verstehe
ich auch ich bin selbst ein
karnevalsjeck aber wir müssen das jetzt
einfach in dieser session durchstehen
und im nächsten jahr können wir wieder
feiern
ob der elfte im nächsten jahr unter
normalen bedingungen stattfinden kann
die jecken zumindest erhoffen sich dass
der hanns-joachim-friedrichs-preis geht
dieses jahr an die bbc journalistin
evelyn mädels und an den leiter des zdf
studios in peking ulf röller unser
korrespondent und sein team
werden für ihre berichte von den
massenprotesten in hongkong und aus
china ausgezeichnet rolle berichtete als
eine der ersten direkt aus wo an dem
ursprungsort des corona virus die jury
schreibt ulf röller und sein team seinen
meister im sammeln von fakten und
eindrücken eine meisterschaft die in
überwachten gesellschaften unabdingbare
voraussetzung für eine seriöse
berichterstattung sei und wir freuen uns
natürlich sehr für den kollegen
jetzt wirst du daran den fußball
freundschaftsspiel gegen tschechien und
genau da will bundestrainer joachim löw
wie schon im oktober beim wilden drei zu
drei testspiel gegen die türkei
ausgiebig experimentieren und vielleicht
gelingt es im jahr mit einem sieg
reichen b-team das augenblickliche
stimmungstief zu überwinden
ganz so dunkel sind die wolken weder
über leipzig noch über der dfb-auswahl
für joachim löw ist heute abend die zeit
viel versprechende nationalmannschafts
neulinge auszuprobieren weil ich so
absolut wert aus meiner sicht dass man
diesen spielern und diesen erweiterten
kader diesen jungen spielern das
vertrauen schenkt ich bin mir sicher die
werden das irgendwann auch zurückzahlen
gegen durch corona ausfälle dezimierte
tschechien will die deutsche mannschaft
verlorene sympathien zurückgewinnen das
spiel in leipzig steht unter dem motto
wir für euch und national torhüter
oliver baumann der hat das dfb team in
leipzig verlassen müssen
der grund seine bundesligamannschaft die
tsg hoffenheim
die hat sich nach mehreren corona fällen
vorsorglich komplett in quarantäne
begeben
baumann musste sich anschließen ja und
auch die beiden corona fälle in der
deutschen handball nationalmannschaft
haben folgen und zwar für die bundesliga
das top spiel heute abend zwischen
flensburg und melsungen ist abgesagt
worden
ebenso zwei partien am morgigen spieltag
nach der island reise am wochenende
ketten marian michalzik und johannes
bitter corona positiv zurück die
spielabsagen die heute in flensburg sind
vorsichtsmaßnahmen
das haben wir prophylaktisch abgesagt
weil wir ihr mit acht nationalspielern
die beteiligt waren den deutschen
länderspielen acht spieler auf der
platte haben und da war uns das risiko
zu großer politisch wieder bislang alle
negativ getestet worden sind
eine woche lang hatte sich das
nationalteam zum lehrgang versammelt die
folgen für den ligabetrieb waren
befürchtet worden dass in kuba
dort war ein paar hoch weil viele
spieler zusammen kommen neu zusammen
kommen und beim igel das ganz genauso da
ist das risiko einfach größer und das
werden wir wieder haben drei
spielverschiebung kann die bundesliga
verkraften werden es mehr wird es
kritisch
und jetzt noch ein ganz besonderer
sportlicher höhepunkt herrliche bilder
man muss kein golf fan sein um sie zu
finden absolut absolut der spanische
golfprofi juden rahmen schlägt beim
turnier in orgaß tor den ball ganz
gezielt flach aufs wasser der landet
dann wieder auf dem grün und rollt und
rollt und rollt macht dann noch so eine
richtig schöne kurve und landet dann
tatsächlich unglaublich aber wahr
im loch einziges manko das kleine nicht
während des wettbewerbs sondern nur beim
training aber egal aber an seinem
geburtstag zum glück beim tippen die
lottozahlen
sie lauten 10 11 19 33 37 38 und die
superzahl 9 weitere gewinnzahlen finden
sie auf lotto zdf de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157 ins wetter kommt bewegung
sagt unsere meteorologin katja horneffer
im nordwesten zieht regen auf den im
wind nimmt zu der nebel ab mehr dazu
gleich hier von ihr
christian sievers freut sich auf sie im
heute journal um viertel vor zehn danke
für ihr großes interesse alles gute ihn
und bis morgen wenn sie morgen auf
wiedersehen